quand il a fallu serrer la main sans
abri j'ai eu un espèce de sentiment de
gêne au début j'étais ramenant c'est
bizarre et tout est en fait ça m'a
marqué de réagir comme ça et je me suis
mis c'est vraiment un gros con ces gens
là ils font ça parce qu'ils utilisent
notre outil moi je suis incapable
d'aller au contact des gens qu'ils
aident et là je me suis dit j'ai un
problème en fait dans mon logiciel de
penser il faut que je change et j'ai du
coup je suis retourné à la maraude la
semaine d'après j'ai mis un point
d'honneur à serrer la main de tous les
mecs que je croisais j'ai même bu dans
des gobelets j'ai même partagé de la
bouffe avec eux et je me suis dit [ __ ]
ok en fait c'est ça que j'ai envie de
faire
[Musique]
c'est vraiment le fait d'être contact
avec des membres qui m'a donné le l'envi
de changer de taff et je trouvais que
aussi mon titre n'était pas juste un
projet associatif et social
c'était aussi une aventure humaine et
même si c'était une aventure
désintéressée nous ce qu'on veut c'est
être indépendant financièrement pour
pouvoir soutenir les causes qui nous
tiennent à coeur
donc on a eu l'idée de développer
financièrement le projet et il y avait
aussi le côté entrepreneurial aventure
de potes trouver une idée pour financer
le projet tout en respectant les valeurs
de la communauté et je trouvais que
c'était les mille fois plus challengeant
que faire des déclarations d'impôts dans
une grande tour de la défense
[Musique]
souvent les gens ils disent comme toi
mais c'est un truc de bons plans bien
non c'est pas un truc de bons plans ça y
est tu peux l'utiliser comme un trou de
bons plans est trop cool que tu fasses
et maintenant nous on veut donner une
dimension sociale et on est déjà en
train de faire en fait tu regardes c'est
très bien tu peux continuer à changer de
colloques et on ne fera jamais payé pour
ça il y aurait jamais le pub sur wanted
et donc on est ravi que tu utilises
notre outil gratuitement et on voulait
juste aussi de montrer qu'il ya d'autres
choses qui se passent sur monte id et
que en fait si toi tu es chez toi avec
tes zita t'engager dans tel ou tel
assaut en fait tu regardes il ya sabrina
elle habite a 100 mètre de chez toi et
elle tous les vendredis elle distribue
deux cents repas aux sans abri et donc
en fait en faisant cohabiter ces deux
types de personnes et ces deux types d'
usage
nous on espère que plus de gens vont
s'engager et plus de gens vont agir
localement et donc oui nous les
cofondateurs en fait on a été impacté
par ça et c'est pour ça qu'on pense que
le mimétisme le fait de voir des gens
faire de belles actions ça peut impacter
d'autres personnes est en fait le fait
qu'on est plus forts tous ensemble à
nous on apprend tous les jours
et du coup on espère que le fait de bien
gérer ces espaces va permettre de le
montrer à d'autres personnes qui sont
sur la communauté et qui s'y attendre
peut-être pas je pense que notre action
est très complémentaire de ce que font
les assauts traditionnel de la mission
nous ont-ils c'est de créer du lien
entre les gens et pour créer ce lien en
fait on a créé des espaces de confiance
où les gens ont des besoins ou des
envies et nous on les aide à réaliser
ses besoins et ses envies et du coup il
ya une vraie question de spontanéité des
actions est en fait si vous avez envie
de ramasser les déchets près de chez
vous et que vous êtes tout seul et que
vous avez envie de mobiliser les gens
wanted peut être un très bon réseau pour
faire ça si vous avez envie d'aller
aider les sans abri dans votre quartier
ont-ils peut être un très bon
agrégateurs et vous pouvez trouver des
gens pour venir vous accompagner et en
fait nous voilà notre action elle se
base surtout sur la spontanéité et les
initiatives citoyennes
on n'a pas de planning on n'a rien et le
but c'est que chacun fasse une petite
partie du boulot et surtout quand il en
a envie et quand il peut